oh i don't want to talk too much about
that but having evan in this world
is amazing it was something that we
talked a lot about on very early on
and i'm so glad we were able to do it
that we were able to make that work
long lost bro get to squeeze his
stinking sister to death or what
[Music]
she recast pietro we're on a cliffhanger
right now
can you talk to me about the
significance of agatha's talk of
chaos magic calling wanda the scarlet
witch
that makes you the scarlet witch
like what is the significance of this
what can you tell us well wanda's had
power for a long time but it's never
been defined
and there is magic in the mcu but we
haven't talked about witches before
and so episode 8 really is about talking
about how there are witches in this
world
agatha's one of them and she is here to
sort of help
uh want to figure out who she really is
and so episode 8 was a lot about looking
at wanda's past but it's also a lot
about destiny
and about what's to come
[Music]
we have to talk about agatha all along
because i i did not
expect there to be a certified bop in
this show
[Music]
well hats off to the lopez's because
they're geniuses
um and hats off to catherine ahan for
singing the heck out of it
along with some amazing backup singers
and doing so well that she managed to
overtake
bieber and the weeknd on the itunes
charts which made me so
happy um but it was a blast to put that
together i mean the
we were going along and in every era we
knew we would have an agatha all along
moments and so there was a lot of
discussion about what those moments
would be
and crafting them through storyboards
and sort of figuring it out and then
we would be shooting something in the
50s and have to stop and kind of
do that agatha all along moment which
would mean
turning to a much more cinematic style
breaking what we were doing and kind of
having
fun with catherine hahn for 45 minutes
to an hour
for that section and i loved every time
we did that
it was always fun we were always coming
up with new ideas um i think my favorite
was coming up with the picnic right
before
we did that we pulled back from pietro
and she's
you know there's han having fun with the
grapes and the wine and
i the poor prop guy elliott had to make
that in like five minutes because he had
no warning
[Music]
and i killed sparky too
those things were really fun and and
help support i think was what a very
catchy tune
very catchy gin that's like one of the
links that people have kind of been
making the whole they're like is agnes
agatha
like could this be her what was the
earliest tell
do you think that agnes was agapa
because there's something in episode one
that people might have missed or
something like that
well you know we've had this cameo there
the broach uh pretty much the whole time
when you announce a character but you
call her just the nosy neighbor and it's
katherine hahn you're
basically inviting uh of the comic fans
to go in a deep dive and see what they
can figure out so
speculation has run rampant around her
role for a long time so we knew that
we would eventually be making this big
reveal and for some they might be
slightly ahead of it
and that's okay as long as the reveal is
a whole lot of fun which i think the
lopez has um
delivered um big time
and for those of us who are not maybe as
familiar with that character or haven't
gone in the deep dive into the comic
books there's hopefully that kaiser soze
moment there as well
where you're surprised and there's some
beautiful scenes
i think in in episode six the one
especially between vision
and agonists over at the edge of town
where
where maybe those who thought they were
on the ag at the train were thrown off a
little bit
um by what they saw there uh so we did
our best to kind of continue with some
red herrings and misdirection along the
way towards that big reveal
it worked uh so we find out that agatha
was
the one that like formed like the evan
peters version of pietro she calls him
fietro which i love
i got close with fake pietro fiatro
um can we talk about this conversation
of bringing evan peters
into the show in this form yeah i mean
she agatha does talk about how
she was manipulating him and controlling
his uh you know pull in the strings
uh where that goes you know there's
still one episode to go i don't want to
talk too much about
that but having evan in this world is
amazing it was something that we talked
a lot about on very early on
and i'm so glad we were able to do it
that we were able to make that work
um he's very special and i think his
work in the show is fantastic
um much like all the other actors he's
capable of so many different tones and
styles and
i love i love uncle ph or uncle p uncle
p
is oh so good so there's there's
potentially more to come with like
what what's going on there with the evan
peters fietro thing
yeah potentially okay was there ever any
talk of bringing
aaron taylor johnson into the mix lots
of conversations were had
um i think this question was asked of
kevin feige uh
last week and i you know that was
definitely something that was discussed
early on
but eventually um a decision was made to
not go down that way
um at least you know um yeah
so there's a very there's like a lot of
the fan theories they're going rampant i
don't know how much you're reading them
but
i just saw a really convincing one about
the significance of the flowers in front
of the houses
are fans on to something with that you
know i have to say
i'm so taken by the level of engagement
with the fans i
we built this show with so much love and
passion and attention to detail
and that we're seeing it come back to us
with so much love and passion from the
fans and we
share these memes and tick tock videos
and everything that's coming out
among the cast and crew and we're just
so um kind of
blown away by the the level of
engagement and also the the
amazing creative spirit that's out there
too um i can't speak about anything
too in too much detail except just to
say um thank you for
all the crazy amazing stuff that you
guys are coming up with i was gonna say
not a no
so we see uh wanda has this like vision
with the mind stone
vision pun intended uh and we see the
fully formed like
scarlet witch look and it's immaculate
can you explain
what's happening here like i said before
i mean episode 8 is a really interesting
episode because it is about going into
wanda's past
so it is about exploring the grief the
loss
the trauma it's also about exploring
love like you know deep love that she
has for vision for her
parents for her brother um all of that
is in that episode as well
but what's past is prologue right
there are also moments of of destiny
implied that all of this is a journey
that she's been on that's been
leading to something when that mind
stone comes to her
it's coming to her for a reason you've
had a lot of debuts and reveals in this
show a lot of
responsibility of debuting characters we
see monica rambo and like kind of how
she gets her powers
which one felt like the biggest
responsibility
they were all equally big um i i think
tiana paris has just crushed it and
her story is a parallel story with wanda
she's
she's dealing with the loss of her
mother she's coming back
into a very sort of disoriented new
world where she's returned from
being gone um she's trying to put the
pieces of her life back together
and so those stories are absolutely
designed to be parallel stories and it's
why
those two characters feel some sort of
affinity uh for each other and it's why
perhaps
wanda brings monica into the world to
begin with
creating um sort of the new version of
monica when she
moves through that hex was a really
exciting moment
for us for all of us tiana just crushes
it and she had to crush it again and
again and again in a million different
outfits as we put that together
um this idea that she was you know being
taken apart
uh and re-made inside this
hex this world was a great moment for us
i think really fun visually but they've
all been
really fun i mean even just opening the
door on on uncle p
at the end of episode five you know as
simple as that is didn't
didn't involve any crazy visual effects
it's still one of my favorite shots
who's a popsicle